The Syndicate is real a rogue nation
trained to do what we do an aunty IMF
good god someone left that old man get
on that plane Jack grandpa tom cruise is
back in the trailer for motion
impossible 5 rogue nation or as i'm
calling it mission impossible 5 maybe
these missions aren't impossible I'm
drew Coolidge and did you see all that
crazy stuff going on that trailer this
might be the best mi movie yet I'll tell
you why in just a second this is hashtag
news Ethan Hunt and the gang will face
their impossible list mission yet when
they uncover the Syndicates a mysterious
network of spies working against them it
looks like the mission impossible
franchise is following the current
action movie trend of the hero facing
off against an evil faceless
organization like Captain America versus
Hydra or James Bond vs. factor or me
versus the Girl Scouts you know gloomy
day gang a paranoid the girls are trying
to control us where we're over priced
than mint and they're bulletproof sashes
open your eyes people how do you know
they're sashes are bulletproof I used to
be one of them more importantly rogue
nation will feature a lot of the same
awesome action sequences from the
previous Mission Impossible movie
impossibly ripped for 52 year old Tom
Cruise breaking out of captivity
doing all his own stunts even though
he's a dad Tom Cruise playing with super
fast motorcycles and seriously I think
he's trying to kill himself Tom Cruise
hanging off of really really high things
over half a century old cruises as fit
as ever and it's clearly in this for the
long haul which is too bad for Jeremy
Renner who was brought in as a potential
replacement in last movie and now seems
like it's just waiting in the wings
hoping the cruise drowns in a whirlpool
maybe one of Brenner's other side
characters will get its own spin-off
franchise maybe not mi5 seems to be
taking a page out of the book a bomb by
including a sexy femme fatale who loves
getting out of water and hates wearing
bras and can kill you with her thighs
but you know who we're almost excited
about these real star of this franchise
America's number one action star Simon
Pegg seriously that guy can play
anything typical freaked out British guy
Simon Pegg fig your seatbelt on you
asking me that now Simon Pegg as the
leading Kingsman becci eats them where
are you Simon Pegg is macklemore maybe
in this age of terrorist networks and
government surveillance every mission a
possible sequel could feature Tom Cruise
fighting a shady faceless organization
trying to destroy society Mission
Impossible 6 Tom Cruise vs. 4chan
Mission Impossible 7 Tom Cruise vs the
Girl Scouts Mission Impossible 8 Tom
Cruise vs the Church of Scientology
forget what I said Tom Cruise's career
is perfect Xenu is the light go see
Mission Impossible rogue nation and give
Tom Cruise all of your money your
mission should you choose to accept it
first like this video next comment with
your favorite part of the new mission
impossible trailer mine with Simon Pegg
being constantly befuddled then
subscribe to new media rock stars
seriously guys we love making these
videos we love hearing from you guys
it's hearing what you think so please
subscribe follow along with us on this
journey so hit subscribe ok I'm drew
Coolidge and I will self-destruct in
five seconds did you guys just put a
bomb in it no no
you